Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Freu dich, bald bringen wir unsere eigene Meme-Coin raus. Die Unicoin.
Da müssen wir aber aufpassen, dass wir da nicht von unseren Kryptofreunden Ärger
kriegen, weil das auf einmal wie Abzocker aussieht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 512.
Wir feiern die Binärpotenz am 24.
Januar 2025.
Tun wir das. Wow.
Bei mir ist der 23. Aber ist egal.
Stimmt, jetzt haben wir, wir haben gerade etwas Zeitzonen-Konfusion. Ihr dürft jetzt raten.
Aber auf jeden Fall macht es gerade die Terminplanung generell etwas schwierig.
Naja, also 23., 24., sucht es euch einfach aus.
Ja, wie ihr wollt. Ist jetzt auch egal.
Ist egal, aber 512, haben wir ja eigentlich, ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen
unser Termin, oder sagen wir mal, es lag schon immer nah, da mal so eine Sondersendung
zu machen. Haben wir jetzt auf die 500 geschoben.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich 512 machen, aber Linus meinte, nee,
ich bin zu faul, wir machen nicht so viel Sendung bis dahin.
Hast du ja auch recht behalten.
Stimmt ja auch, hatte ich auch recht.
Sehr realistischer. Einschätzung, aber jetzt ist es soweit. Und ja,
weiß ich nicht, mal gucken.
Vielleicht wird es ja trotzdem eine besondere Sendung. Who knows?
Wir wurden übrigens zurechtgewiesen, dass wir in den ganzen 500ern jetzt nicht
unbedingt immer alle Status Codes mitgeliefert haben.
Das stimmt.
Und das stimmt. Das ist wirklich gar nicht gut, weil wir eigentlich seit der
Service Unavailable haben wir noch gemacht. aber Gateway Timeout,
HTTP Version Not Supported haben wir glaube ich gemacht.
Irgendwann haben wir es auch mal zusammengefasst und dann wieder,
ich weiß auch nicht, irgendwie ist es, es hat sich so ein bisschen, naja.
Aber bei Ausgleich bei 512 ist es halt Ende, ne?
Ja, jetzt können wir sozusagen bis 599 sagen, gibt's nicht.
Ja, schade.
Ja, das ist doof. Also, that ship has sailed, Leute, wir müssen was Neues einfallen
lassen. Das ist ja auch einfach viel zu nötig.
Ja, zum Beispiel könntest du irgendwie wieder was von den goldenen 20ern erzählen.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Ich werde mich nie daran gewöhnen, Leute. Es tut mir leid, ich werde auch nicht sagen, tut oder tröt.
Es gab einen schönen Tweet auf Mastodon, wo jemand meinte, wenn wir jetzt noch
ein Loch finden, wo wir die Brechstange reinhalten können, dann sind die goldenen
Zwanziger eigentlich da.
Kuchenblech-Mafia kennst du, ne?
Nee.
Also man muss ja eine Referenz zu Kuchenblech-Mafia...
Kuchenblech-Mafia, muss man erklären, weiß ich nicht. Kenn ich nicht. Was ist das?
Internet-Basiswissen. Kennst du nicht die Kuchenblech-Mafia?
Breaking News. Auch ich weiß nicht alles. Ich weiß, das ist ein Gedanke,
an den man sich sehr schwer gewöhnen kann, aber es gibt diesen Riss in der Matrix,
wo selbst mir ab und zu mal ein Detail verloren geht. Wo ist das?
Da ist ein Fernsehteam irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, RBB, weiß der Geier,
zu einer Firma gegangen, die Geldschränke verkauft.
Und diese Firma, die Geldschränke verkauft, sagt, wie schlecht.
Diese Panzerknacker.
Ja, Kuchenblech-Mafia. Und die sagen dann, sie machen jetzt mal eben schnell
den Tresor der Konkurrenz auf. Eben kurz so.
Der ist eigentlich offen.
Im Prinzip ist der jetzt schon offen. Und genau, Kuchenblech-Mafia.
Also wer das nicht kennt, Kuchenblech-Mafia ist auf einer Ebene mit...
Ja, weiß ich nicht, wie hießen die nochmal? Soko-Farbe da, die in der Hafenstraße
das Haus da angegangen sind.
Eine Internet-Legende und ich erinnere mich jetzt auch, ich hatte es unter diesem
Begriff überhaupt nicht abgespeichert.
Und ich hoffe, meine Reputation als Internet-Auskenner ist wiederhergestellt worden.
Ist wiederhergestellt.
Die ist auf jeden Fall in den Shownotes.
Ich bin mir sogar nicht sicher, ob nicht eventuell sogar du mich irgendwann
mal vor vielen Jahren darauf hingewiesen hast, mich gerügt hast,
dass ich wohl gar nicht richtig hingucke im Internet, dass ich sowas nicht kenne.
Bist du nur zum Spatz im Internet oder was?
Als wir uns kennengelernt haben, da warst du ja auch noch kleiner,
kanntest du ja noch gar nichts. Die große Welt.
Die Tür muss sich erstmal aufmachen.
Genau.
Jetzt bist du so ein Emporkömmling und denkst, du kennst alles.
Mal gucken. Mir fällt schon noch was an.
Ja, jetzt schicke ich anderen Leuten Links.
So fängt es an mit dem Alter. Und irgendwann fangen ja Leute dann an,
von dir irgendwelchen Memes zu erzählen, von denen du noch nie was gehört hast.
Und dann denkst du dir so, oh.
Dann denkst du dir, scheiße, hab ich doch noch ein Leben. Okay,
pass auf, wir fangen mit Feedback an.
Gab es einiges.
Wir fangen an mit einem Feedback von Max per E-Mail. Max sagt,
es geht jetzt im Feedback-Bereich elektronische Patientenakte.
Werden da ja festgestellt, dass da in weiten Teilen einfach mal wirklich gegen
sämtlichen gesunden Menschenverstand,
verstoßen wurde bei den Sicherheits Gegen den gesunden Programmiererverstand.
Sagen wir es mal so.
Den gesunden Kleinkindverstand, ja,
also das große, Max schreibt, hallo ihr zwei, das große Problem mit dieser EPA
und im Allgemeinen mit der TI, Telematikinfrastruktur, ist doch,
dass wir Ärzte und auch die Patienten dem vollkommen hilflos ausgeliefert sind.
Wir Ärzte werden praktisch erpresst, teilzunehmen.
Bis Ende letztes Jahr habe ich mich noch dagegen gewehrt, musste aber im Gegenzug
am Schluss über 1000 Euro Strafe pro Monat zahlen.
Gleichzeitig dürfen die Unternehmen, die diesen Schrott produzieren,
machen, was sie wollen und haben im Falle solcher Fehltritte keine Strafe zu befürchten.
Entweder bezahlen wir es mit unseren Daten oder wir Praxisbetreiber mit unserem
Geld, wenn mal wieder alles ausfällt und wir mehr Arbeit haben und Hilfe in
Anspruch nehmen müssen, um die Probleme zu lösen.
Da habe ich auch wenig Mitleid mit Lauterbach und seinen Vorgängern.
Die haben den Schrott so abgesegnet und gerade Lauterbach ist dafür bekannt,
dass er immer sehr verständnisvoll tut und am Schluss nicht liefert.
Innerhalb der ärztlichen Fronten oder Fraktionen ist er zumindest ziemlich unbeliebt.
Vielen Dank für eure Folge.
Ja,
das ist, ich meine, das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Ich meine, der Staat sagt so hier, bitte Infrastruktur alle mal betreiben und
wenn ihr daran nicht mitwirken wollt, dann zahlt ihr Geld.
Und wenn ihr dann die Infrastruktur betreibt und dann funktioniert sie nicht
richtig, dann habt ihr auch einen Schaden davon. Also das ist schon,
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Also wenn ich in so einer Branche wäre, womit der Staat so eine Scheißinfrastruktur
und so eine Scheißsoftware vor die Nase setzen würde, ich würde auch an die
Decke gehen. Aber so richtig.
Also wie sagt man, man geht dann nuklear oder….
Da musst du den Arzt fragen, was man dann mal am besten setzt.
Ich kann ja mal Max fragen.
Was nimmst du eigentlich dagegen?
Also grundsätzlich fände ich das jetzt nicht, also ich bin nur nicht unmittelbar
dem Gedanken abgeneigt, dass man jetzt allen Praxen sagt, ihr müsst den Quatsch jetzt hier machen.
Ihr könnt nicht einfach uns eine Rechnung aus eurer Buchhaltung schicken oder
was auch immer, warum die da gezwungen werden.
Es ist schon verständlich, dass man da eine einheitliche, vernünftige Infrastruktur
braucht. Aber dann doch bitte auch eine vernünftige.
Das wäre doch alles, was wir verlangen. Wir sind doch gar nicht dagegen.
Wir haben uns ja immer sehr vorsichtig zu der Frage verhalten,
ob man der elektronischen Patientenakte widersprechen soll oder nicht.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Haben das euch offen gelassen. Gibt es übrigens einen sehr nicht irrelevanten Hinweis.
Man kann den Widerspruch natürlich auch wieder rückgängig machen.
Das heißt, man kann natürlich sagen,
und da wird dann auch der EPA-Widerspruch eventuell zu einem politischen Druck
noch ist das irgendwo so im einstelligen Prozentbereich.
Aber wenn da genug Leute sagen, in dem Zustand mache ich da nicht mit,
seht mal bitte zu, dass das was Ordentliches wird, dann ist das natürlich,
Vor dem Hintergrund dessen, dass man, wenn das dann eine halbwegs vernünftige
Infrastruktur ist, den Widerspruch zurücknehmen kann, auch möglicherweise ein
politisches Protestmittel.
Gut, Martino schreibt zur elektronischen Patientenakte.
Das wundert mich überhaupt nicht. Ich beobachte schon lange,
dass IT-Security primär von Leuten gemacht wird, die noch nie eine Zeile Code geschrieben haben.
Da wundert es auch nicht, dass sich das Sicherheitskonzept ausführlich damit
beschäftigt, wie man die Meldefrist auch einhält, wenn Ostern im Schaltjahr
auf einen Dienstag fällt.
Das können viele Menschen noch mit Word, Excel und PowerPoint lösen.
Dafür muss man einfach nur die Vorschriften kennen. Aber niemand guckt mal nach,
ob die ganzen Zertifikate etc.
Nicht überhaupt korrekt benutzt werden. Also das im Sicherheitskonzept Geschriebene
tatsächlich umgesetzt ist.
Dafür müsste man sich halt auskennen und was drauf haben. Würde man die Security
ordentlich machen, kämen diese ganzen Meldefristen auch nicht zur Anwendung.
Dass das nun auch im Gesundheitswesen, speziell bei gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
passiert, ist auch nicht überraschend.
Die Branche gilt als Selbstbedienungsladen, bei dem alle nur ihren Besitzstand waren.
Ja, also diesen Kommentar habe ich deswegen mit aufgenommen.
Ich arbeite ja in der IT-Sicherheit, konzentriere mich primär auf technische
IT-Sicherheit und schon auch Organisationsstrukturen um technische Sicherheit herzustellen.
Aber sagen wir mal so, mir fallen da auch immer mal wieder Leute auf,
die mit dieser Checklisten-Security, und hier müssen wir noch was schreiben,
kannst du hier noch was unterschreiben, hast aber hier, und da müssen wir aber
Zustimmung, und hier müssen wir auch noch irgendwie,
und können wir mal das sehen, und hier dürft ihr übrigens nicht hacken im Rahmen
eures Thread-Teams oder so.
Also irgendein Quatsch, wo die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Juristen oder sonstigen
Leute, die keine fucking Ahnung haben und die wirklich halt einfach in allem, was sie tun,
wo du wirklich hingehen kannst und sagen kannst, pass auf, alles was du tust,
führt zu einer Schwächung der Sicherheit deines Unternehmens,
weil du einer vernünftigen IT-Sicherheit im Weg stehst.
Das war ja unter anderem auch bei Carriot so eines der Probleme,
dass dann da der Laden so zu Tode reguliert ist, dass die eigenen Entwickler
nicht mehr das eigene Problem lösen können, weil sie wiederum,
oder sagen wir mal, ihre Forensik nicht betreiben können, weil sie aus Datenschutzgründen
auf irgendwas nicht Zugriff haben dürfen.
Insofern ja, dieser ganze IT-Security-Bereich, auch in Ermangelung von Leuten,
die halt einfach mal hacken können und Sachen sicher machen und wissen,
wie Scheiße geht, wird halt dann, das scheint mir so ein Default zu sein,
das wird dann alles immer von Juristen übernommen.
Und dann sagen irgendwelche Juristen, ja das darfst du nicht machen,
das darfst du nicht machen, das darfst du nicht machen und dann wundern sie sich,
dass sie irgendwie jahrzehntelang Papier produziert haben und dann ihre Bude aufgemacht wird,
weil irgendwie einfach Basisfehler gemacht werden und alle daran gehindert werden,
so was überhaupt aufzudecken oder zu beheben.
Insofern ja, ja Martino, ja.
We feel you.
Ja, we feel you. Dann haben wir, Chris sagt, hallo, habt ihr wohl die Stellungnahme
der Gematik nicht gelesen? Link findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Da ist zu lesen, dass die praktische Durchführung eines Angriffs in der Realität
nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist, unter anderem, weil unberechtigte Zugriffe auf die EPA strafbar sind.
Und nicht nur Geld, sondern auch Freiheitsstrafen nach sich ziehen können.
Das ist ja auch genau der gleiche, das ist ja verboten, das geht ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja unwahrscheinlich, dass das jemand macht, das haben wir doch verboten.
Das hatte ich überhaupt nicht gedacht, also das stellt ja eigentlich alles auf den Kopf.
Ja, this changes everything. Ja, genau. Mit so einem Scheiß.
Okay, dann haben wir noch einen etwas längeren Kommentar von Marc.
Jetzt geht es um das Carrier-Daten-Lag.
Und ihr erinnert euch, beim Carrier-Daten-Lag werde ich ja nicht müde zu betonen,
dass ich das Problem nicht unbedingt darin sehe, dass da eine Fehlkonfiguration stattgefunden hat.
Und die Daten ungeschützt waren, sondern da sehe ich das Problem darin,
dass diese Daten überhaupt gesammelt wurden und keiner der Betroffenen das wusste.
Oder zumindest ich keinen Betroffenen finden konnte und sich auch nie einer
bei mir gemeldet hat, der gesagt hat, ach so, ja klar, nee, das habe ich unterschrieben,
dass da meine Daten in irgendeiner Amazon-Cloud rumgammeln,
über mehrere Jahre und zwar jeder Zeitpunkt, wo ich die Karre gestartet oder abgeschaltet habe.
Nee, nee, ist völlig in Ordnung. Das geschieht mit meiner vollen Zustimmung. Das finde ich auch gut.
Das gibt es ja einfach nicht.
Habe ich auch noch nicht von gehört.
Nee, das passiert einfach nicht. Und jetzt sagt der, also Marc sagt,
Linus oder ihr beide stellt mehrmals die Frage, an welcher Stelle eigentlich
eine Einwilligung der Betroffenen eingeholt wurde, die die Speicherung der Standortdaten
der Fahrzeuge rechtfertigen würde.
Die Einwilligung in die Verarbeitung ist nur ein möglicher Rechtfertigungsbestand
für Datenverarbeitung, die die
DSGVO in Artikel 6 Absatz 1 unter Absatz 1 Buchstaben A bis F vorsieht.
Daneben kommt beispielsweise das berechtigte Interesse des für die Verarbeitung
Verantwortlichen Buchstabe F oder die Erfüllung eines Vertrages Buchstabe B in Betracht.
Kann sich ein Verantwortlicher auf einen dieser Rechtfertigungsgründe stützen,
wäre die Einwilligung nicht erforderlich.
Allerdings muss bei berechtigtem Interesse und Vertragserfüllung die Verarbeitung
der Daten erforderlich, also zwingend notwendig sein und darf nur im nötigen
Maß erfolgen, wie der EuGH erst vor kurzem entschieden hat.
Daher könnte Linus Szenario, dass die Daten erhoben wurden, um die Batterieleistung
bei unterschiedlichen Temperaturen zu bewerten, ein berechtigtes Interesse darstellen.
Ob dafür die präzise Erhebung des Standortes erforderlich ist oder nur die grobe
Erhebung auf 10 Kilometer, wie es bei einigen Marken ja der Fall war,
kann ich nicht einschätzen.
So oder so wäre VW in der Verantwortung darzulegen, warum die Verarbeitung der
Daten, ob präzise oder grobe, erforderlich ist.
Außerdem müsste VW über die Verarbeitung der Daten transparent informieren, nach Artikel 13 DSGVO.
Da wäre es mal spannend, die Datenschutzerklärung
für ein betroffenes Elektroauto zu Gesicht zu bekommen.
Eine Einwilligung irgendwo in den AGB zu verstecken, ist in der Praxis vermutlich
nicht selten, aber explizit nicht erlaubt.
Kurzer Hinweis dazu also danke für die Erläuterung, man merkt dass ich Hacker
bin und kein Jurist tatsächlich findest du in den Show Notes zur letzten Sendung,
so eine Datenschutzerklärung.
Die habe ich da schon reingepackt und da steht auch irgendwas von berechtigtem
Interesse drin, insofern hast du hier glaube ich genau getroffen,
lieber lieber Marc Marc schreibt aber noch weiter.
Etwas schmunzeln musste ich, dass VW versucht, sich darüber rauszureden,
dass die GPS-Daten Fahrzeugdaten wären und keine personenbezogene Daten.
Richtig ist, dass Maschinendaten nicht unter die DSGVO fallen,
weil nur personenbezogene Daten geschützt werden.
Es gilt aber kein gegenseitiger Ausschluss, also dass Maschinendaten automatisch
keine personenbezogene Daten sein können.
Maschinendaten können auch personenbezogene Daten sein, wie der EuGH beispielsweise
in Bezug auf IP-Advorschläge. Adressen schon vor Langem entschieden hat.
Aber angesichts der Situation, in der VW da gerade ist, greift man vielleicht
erstmal jeden Strohhalm, den man finden kann.
Daher kann ich Linus' Irritation gut verstehen.
Mich persönlich beruhigt aber, dass die DSGVO das eigentlich alles schon regelt.
Es müssten sich die Leute jetzt nur noch daran halten.
Das könnte ein bisschen schwierig werden. Ja.
Ich denke einfach, es ist so ein ganz gut nachvollziehbarer Default-Reiz,
den man glaube ich so auch im Software-Bereich hat.
Erstmal alles nehmen und dann mal gucken, wofür man das verwenden kann.
Selbst wenn man die gute Intention hat, später das in irgendeiner Form noch
zu reduzieren auf das, was man wirklich braucht oder was sich dann wirklich
rechtlich durchsetzen lässt,
nur dass dann irgendwie zu dem Zeitpunkt dann schon keiner mehr daran denkt,
dass man das sich ja eigentlich nochmal genauer anschauen wollte.
Also es ist jetzt kein Versuch, das irgendwie zu erklären oder rauszureden,
aber es ist halt noch so eine Routine, die glaube ich alle im Kopf haben und
kann durchaus sein, dass so ein Faktor hier mit reinspielt, wenn man jetzt nicht
unbedingt immer gleich böse Absicht unterstellen möchte.
Oft ist ja Dusseligkeit und Nachlässigkeit sehr viel eher der Grund als jetzt vorgesetztes Handeln.
Was es jetzt am Ende nicht besser macht, klar. und schon gar nicht,
wenn man dann noch so nachlässig mit den Backups im Netz umgeht,
den Schuh müssen sie sich auf jeden Fall anziehen.
Ja, absolut.
Man muss natürlich auch nochmal einen Unterschied machen zwischen Tim programmiert
ein bisschen auf seinem Mac rum und du bist irgendwie ein Milliardenkonzern,
der halt Kfz-Daten lockt.
Da muss man schon, also in einer solchen Organisation müssen übliche Programmierimpulse
schon irgendwie sortiert werden.
Fred hat auch noch einen Grund, warum alles scheiße ist.
Moin, Linus meinte irgendwann, dass er sich frage, warum in der ganzen Wertschöpfungskizze
niemand merkt, dass das, was man da gerade baut, scheiße ist.
Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, ob es zur EPA oder zur Wahlsoftware war,
ist aber für meine Einschätzung auch egal.
Aus meiner beruflichen Erfahrung heraus möchte ich die Vermutung aufstellen,
dass sehr wohl Mitarbeitende der beteiligten Firmen gemerkt und auch vielleicht
geäußert haben, dass sie Bauchweh bekommen.
Nur hören Manager heute nicht mehr auf Ingenieure. Sie lesen irgendwas ganz
Tolles im Manager-Magazin oder in der Elektrotechnik und denken dann,
wie die Technik funktioniert.
Ich habe die letzten zwei Firmen verlassen, weil Manager uns praktisch in jeder
Frage überstimmt haben und wir Fusch bauen mussten.
Immer mit dem Argument, wir würden sonst Großkunden verlieren.
In meiner letzten Firma sind aus diesem Grund jedes Jahr zwei, drei Leute gegangen.
So schnell kann gar nicht nachbesetzt werden, sodass nun noch fünf Leute da
sind von 30 vor fünf Jahren, die keine Zeit mehr haben, sich über Sinn und Unsinn
ihrer Arbeit Gedanken zu machen.
Also ich denke mal, dass Sinus das schon so gemeint hatte, dass sich da kein
Verantwortlicher gefunden hat, dem mal auffällt, dass man Scheiße baut.
Wollte nur einmal die Lanze brechen für die Entwickler, die gerne einfach mal
alles ordentlich machen würden und die daher in vielen Firmen unerwünscht sind.
Und die Entwickler, die so etwas ungeschimpft mitmachen, sollen sich sofort
in die Ecke stellen und schämen.
Ja, ähm.
Also ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Phänomen, dass Leute,
die Dinge ordentlich machen wollen,
früher oder später mit dem konfrontiert
werden, was andere im Unternehmen ökonomische Realität nennen.
Und also was auf jeden Fall in fast jeder Firma, also wenn du eine Firma hast
und lässt die ein paar Jahre, weiß nicht, lässt die drei Jahre Code schreiben,
dann wirst du dort sehr schnell Stimmen hören, die sagen, das muss man alles neu schreiben.
Das muss man alles einmal neu machen.
Und ich glaube, in genau der gleichen Firma wirst du immer jemanden hören,
der sagt, ja, das machen wir dann nächstes Jahr und jetzt knotest du die Scheiße
da irgendwie rein, bitte, weil ich habe hier eine Deadline zu erfüllen.
Ja, ich habe gerade in den Shownotes auch nochmal einen Link zum SNAFU-Prinzip
hinzugefügt, was auch eine ganz gute Erklärung sein kann dafür.
Mit dem SNAFU-Prinzip vertraut.
Situation normal, all fucked up.
Ja genau, aber das NAFO-Prinzip ist sozusagen, dass sehr wohl solche Probleme
unten gesehen werden, aber dann während es dann die Hierarchiekette innerhalb
der Organisation nach oben getragen wird,
fügt jeder so ein bisschen seine eigene Sichtweise mit dazu,
bis irgendwie diese Warnmeldung im Prinzip als Bestätigung der vorhandenen Prozesse
gesehen wird und nichts ändert sich.
Das ist im Kern das NAFO-Prinzip.
Okay, dann haben wir noch ein bisschen Feedback bekommen zum Begriff soziale
oder asoziale Medien und da hat Christian etwas gesagt,
also ich fand das sehr einen interessanten Hinweis, weil der für mich tatsächlich
relevant war. Zum Begriff soziale Medien.
Ich halte das schon lange für einen Anglizismus bzw. eine Fehlübersetzung.
Gemeint ist eigentlich nur, dass diese Medien von der Gesellschaft bespielt
werden und eben nicht nur Journalisten. Der Begriff Social ist nicht deckungsgleich mit Sozial.
Anders ausgedrückt, bei Social Media ist nicht gemeint, dass es hier besonders
empathisch zugeht oder es um ein Miteinander geht, im Gegensatz zu Begriffen
wie soziales Engagement, Sozialstaat,
Sozialhelfer etc.
Auch das von Facebook verwendete Wort Friend ist nicht identisch zu Freund,
sondern eher sowas wie ein Bekannter.
Das ist wirklich ein hervorragender Kommentar. Das kann man eigentlich gar nicht genug hervorheben.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich ärgere mich fast schon ein bisschen, dass mir das nicht
selber auch schon längst in der Sprache so bewusst geworden ist,
dass halt Social Media eigentlich sehr viel mehr eben mit Gesellschaftsmedien
übersetzt werden müsste in unserer deutschen Begriffswelt.
Einfach um klar zu machen, worum es dabei eigentlich geht.
Ja, und weißt du was, ich habe diese Assoziation überhaupt nicht, weil für mich sozial,
zumindest in diesem Kontext, also kann daran liegen,
dass ich relativ viel Englisch spreche oder kann daran liegen,
dass ich halt Psychologie studiert habe, aber für mich bezieht sich sozial einfach
auf Zusammenleben und Beziehungen zwischen Menschen oder Gruppen.
Also Sozialpsychologie hat ja auch nicht etwas mit,
also es ist nicht etwas genuin Positives, es wird einfach sozial,
also es ist ein soziales Phänomen, ein Phänomen, das mehr als zwei Personen,
dann wäre es Beziehung, betrifft.
Deswegen habe ich diese ganze Sozialarbeiter oder Assoziationen nicht. Haben andere Leute die?
Also ist das etwas, was du glaubst, was Leute haben? Wahrscheinlich schon, ne?
Ich denke, ja. Also das, sagen wir mal so, es schwebt natürlich immer drin,
weil wenn du von sozialen Medien redest, ja, dann, ich meine,
wo benutzt du denn sonst den Begriff sozial?
Und das sehen wir ja gerade in dieser... Wenn ich sage, jemand ist asozial.
Ja genau, also gerade diese,
weil dadurch haben wir das ja sozusagen jetzt überhaupt erst ins Spiel gebracht,
dass man halt sozial asozial bringt und das sagt ja schon mal ganz klar,
was die primäre Wahrnehmung dieses Begriffes ist, wenn einem das quasi als Gegenteil dazu einfällt.
Dabei ist ja sozusagen das asoziale Medium ist sozusagen eins,
was ich eben nicht mit den gesellschaftlichen Dingen zusammen,
also sozusagen so LinkedIn.
Das heißt, es geht ja um Business, das ist dann sozusagen asozial.
Nein, jetzt übertreibe ich ein bisschen,
aber definitiv ist es etwas, was man im Kopf behalten muss und das mit diesem
Friend ist insofern auch ein sehr guter Hinweis,
das war mir allerdings sehr wohl bekannt, trotzdem, also dieses ganze Freunde gewinnen,
ich weiß nicht, wie es dir so ging, als diese Befreunderei losgingen.
Und man dann so, ja, hier, jemand will dich dann hier befreunden,
sozusagen. Also alles auf Englisch auf diesen ganzen Medien.
Und ich denke mir immer so, das sind aber alles gar nicht meine Freunde.
Also ich habe da ein ganz anderes Ding und dabei ist es halt Ich.
Habe da nie mitgemacht.
Ja, ich habe da auch nicht mitgemacht, aber ich habe halt unter anderem auch
schon deshalb nicht mitgemacht, weil ich da einfach so eine Aversion habe,
irgendwelche dahergelaufenen Leute auf dem Internet sozusagen in meinen Freundeskreis aufzunehmen.
Und an der Stelle funktioniert diese sprachliche Definition für uns irgendwie nicht.
Zumindest sind die Übersetzung nicht so.
Ich meine, oft ist es ja so, dass die allgemeine,
Art und Weise, wie man, also dass die englischen Begriffe so sehr in unseren
Sprachraum einziehen, dass wir
sie einfach auch normal und in gewisser Hinsicht auch richtig benutzen.
Jetzt fällt mir natürlich gerade ein gutes Beispiel ein, aber wir sind ja so
durchverdenglisch, dass es quasi oft schon normaler wirkt, den englischen Begriff zu benutzen.
Oft kollidiert aber dann eben dann doch einfach auch mit unseren deutschen Worten,
die wir nicht bereit sind von heute auf morgen aufzugeben.
Und wenn du dann eben so falsche Freunde hast, wie man so schön sagt,
also dass wir so diese Wahrnehmung haben, von was eigentlich etwas bedeuten
sollte, aber es tatsächlich was anderes bedeutet, so I become a beefsteak.
Dann bricht es halt irgendwie auseinander.
Und da ist, glaube ich, auch so die Deutsch-Englisch-Grenze manchmal ein bisschen schwierig.
Die Franzosen machen das ja ganz anders, die übersetzen ja dann auch wirklich nahezu alles.
Weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch machen wahrscheinlich in der aktuellen Jugendkultur.
Auch nicht mehr so sehr, aber da legt man seine Finger noch auf die Tastatur
des Ordinateurs individuell.
Ja, ist auch in Ordnung.
Die sozialen, die sogenannten sozialen Medien, übrigens noch ganz kurz,
der eigentliche Begriff, also das eigentliche Gegenteil von sozial ist antisozial, ja.
Asozial ist ein Schimpfwort, deswegen sage ich das auch so gerne.
So, dann haben wir Social Media und die US-Wahl.
Wir haben eine anonyme Person,
hat in einem Substack-Blog einen Beitrag geschrieben und hat gesagt,
sie hätte vorher bei Twitter gearbeitet, dann wurde das X.
Und sie sei Teil eines Teams gewesen,
das die direkte Anweisung hatte, Twitter-Systeme so zu manipulieren,
dass sie die US Presidential Election 2024 beeinflussen.
Sie hätten dafür den Algorithmus so verändert, dass Pro-Trump- und Right-Wing-Inhalte
an die Spitze der Feeds der Leute kamen.
Sie haben teilweise auch mal irgendwas Linkes mit hochgeschoben,
damit das nicht so auffällt.
Und sie hätten dann tausende von Fake-Accounts betrieben und zwar mit Advanced-AI-Systems
namens Grog und Elisa. Ja.
So diese Grog und Elisa, das sind, im Prinzip definierst du da so mit so einem
Character-File eine Person und sagst so hier, die ist so und so,
die würde ungefähr solche Dinge sagen und da geht es darum, was weiß ich,
der Markt, die Inflation ist zu hoch und der Markt muss besser werden oder sowas.
Und dann sagen sie, also hier schreibt diese anonyme Person,
die hätten sie zu tausenden damit Fake-Accounts betrieben.
Außerdem hätte ein Team irgendwelche Fake-Artikel geschrieben,
während ein anderes Team die künstlich auf Twitter geboostet hätte,
dass sie besseres Engagement bekommen und dadurch viral gingen.
Also sie hätten quasi aktiv Fake-News erstellt und mithilfe von Twitter verbreitet.
Und das ist erstmal so die Schilderung. Jetzt liefert die Person aber leider keine Belege.
Sie sagt einfach nur so, ihr werdet merken, dass das, was ich sage,
die Wahrheit ist, wenn ihr die Reaktion von Elon Musk auf die Nachricht seht,
dass es jemand letztendlich ausgesprochen hat.
Und guckt euch die Elisa AI Agent Software an.
Wir haben Brotkrumen zurückgelassen, also quasi wir haben Hinweise hinterlassen.
Und wenn du dann irgendwie in dieses Repo gehst, wo dieses Elisa drin ist,
da sind dann zum Beispiel in den Character Files sind dann so Pro-Trump-Personen.
Und der Hinweis, den diese Person jetzt also machen will, ist,
dass sie da quasi eine kleine,
die Aussage, die diese Person machen will, ist, dass sie quasi in der Dokumentation
des Codes, wie man ihn anwendet, Beispiele hinterlassen haben für tatsächlich genutzte Accounts.
Zu den Fake-Accounts, die da betrieben wurden, sagt sie aber,
habt ihr euch nicht auch gewundert, dass die auf einmal alle wieder weg waren?
Und da wäre natürlich ein sehr viel schönerer Beweis, den die Person bringen
könnte, wenn sie jetzt sagen würde,
hier sind die tausende Fake-Accounts, die wir betrieben haben und die jetzt
weg sind. Und das war dieses Team.
Das wäre dann natürlich ein Beweis.
Insofern, ehrlich gesagt, finde ich, das ist so ein bisschen so,
alles, was die Person da sagt, finde ich absolut glaubwürdig.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch so.
Trotzdem ist es nicht glaubhaft, dass sie daran beteiligt war,
weil sie halt einfach keine Beweise liefert oder keinerlei Erkenntnisse,
die in irgendeiner Weise beweisen könnten, dass sie das tatsächlich erlebt hat oder nicht.
Ja, das ist wirklich schwierig, das zu beurteilen. Ich meine,
das klingt natürlich jetzt alles auch erstmal durchaus nachvollziehbar,
aber das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen das Problem mit solchen Meldungen.
Das passt jetzt auch so ein bisschen in das Weltbild rein.
Also es kann halt sehr gut sein, dass es auch nicht so stattgefunden hat.
Kann aber auch sein. Das ist gut gerade bei uns.
Wenn wir uns jetzt gerade mal anschauen, wie Elon Musk freidreht und,
ganz offensichtlich ja nun Twitter zu so einem Nazi Trompete umgebaut hat,
dann wäre das jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht nur die konsequente Fortführung davon.
Kann also sein, ich hoffe, dass wir da auch noch mehr erfahren,
ob jetzt hier sozusagen was dran ist, aber der Post ist so erstmal nicht wirklich hilfreich.
Also das ist der eine Teil, das haben ja nun wirklich auch alle gemerkt,
dass bei Twitter sehr schnell nach der Übernahme durch Musk auf einmal ein anderer
Wind wehte und dieser andere Wind sich vor allem daran bemerkbar machte,
dass da auf einmal komplett andere Inhalte einem reingeflogen sind,
die man nicht bestellt hatte, denen man nicht gefolgt ist und dass halt die
kuratierte Timeline gegeben wurde.
Das ist etwas, was immer die Diskussion um, dass es eine kuratierte Timeline
gab und dass sie irgendwie,
also kuratierte Timeline heißt, ursprünglich hast du eine Timeline gehabt und
das waren chronologisch die Beiträge der Leute, denen du gefolgt bist und die
wiederum vielleicht retweetet haben. Das war Twitter.
Und das war aber bei Facebook wohl früher auch so. Ich erinnere mich,
da habe ich noch bei Netzpolitik.org geschrieben, das wird dann wahrscheinlich
so 2010, 2011 gewesen sein, dass das irgendwie Thema war, dass Facebook die
kuratierte Timeline zum Standard machte.
Und gesagt haben, hör mal, lass doch mal die kuratierte Timeline hier dir angucken.
Kannst du mit 85 Sondereinstellungen in 84 Menüs auch gerne wieder wegmachen, kein Problem.
Und warum hatte Facebook das vielleicht mal irgendwann gemacht?
So, naja, weil sie dachten, naja, die Dinge, die vielleicht keinen interessieren,
die können wir ja dann auch einfach weglassen, dann ist die,
haben die Leute insgesamt eine bessere Facebook-Erfahrung.
Aber natürlich ist in diesem, lass uns mal aussuchen, was wir dir anzeigen,
genau die Macht drin, Menschen in die eine Realität zu zerren oder in die andere.
Und dass Elon Musk, also das hat Elon Musk ja auch absolut unverhohlen gesagt,
dass er da irgendwie dafür sorgen würde,
dass da jetzt Freiheit und Rede und Wahrheit kommen, wenn er an den Algorithmen fuchtelt.
Also das, das, das, das, also,
Das ist ja noch nicht mal eine News. Ob sie da jetzt Fake-Accounts mit künstlicher
Intelligenz betrieben haben?
Naja, ich meine, wisst ihr jetzt auch nicht, warum die ausgerechnet das nicht machen sollten.
Ja, also es ist erstmal jetzt eine Meldung,
wir haben das jetzt hier so präsentiert, weil das kann man jetzt auch nicht
komplett ignorieren, aber wir sagen jetzt halt auch nicht, das ist der Beweis,
das ist hier die Smoking Gun, aber es gibt natürlich schon Hinweise,
dass es sozusagen bei Elon Musk und seinem technologischen Umfeld so leichte Rechtstendenzen gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das schon aufgefallen ist, aber mutmaßlich verhält er sich.
Hat er allen sein Herz geschenkt.
Ja, also es ist, genau, mutmaßlich hat er so eine Art Nazi-Yoga irgendwie am
Start, weil er komische Bewegungen macht.
Lobby Control hat da mal was,
getwittert auf Mastodon seit dem Musk Talk auf X hat Alice Weidels Account dort über 230.000,
Followerinnen dazu gewonnen 170.000 dieser neuen Followerinnen kamen am Tag
des Gesprächs mit Musk dazu das alles ist auch für die Beurteilung wichtig,
ob es sich bei dem Talk auf X um eine Parteispende gehandelt haben könnte.
Dabei wäre nicht der Talk selbst die Parteispende, sondern die algorithmische
Bevorzugung, die alle Musk-Aktivitäten auf seiner Plattform erhalten.
Dieses Boosting wird normalerweise von X verkauft, bekommt die AfD es umsonst,
wäre es eine geldferte Leistung.
Das wiederum wäre illegal, da sowohl Musk als auch X in den USA sitzen und Parteispenden
von außerhalb der EU nicht erlaubt sind.
Wie erwartet wurde das Gespräch auch vielen Userinnen als besondere Benachrichtigung
angezeigt und in der Seitenleiste angepinnt, auch wenn sie Musk nicht folgten.
Ja, also ich meine, also das war ja nun mal so.
Das ist ja jetzt gar keine, also, ne, das ist, war halt einfach so.
Gibt's gar keine Diskussion.
Insofern, ähm.
Ja, der benutzt diese Plattform, die er sich da gekauft hat,
zur massenhaften Einflussnahme auf die Öffentlichkeit in seinem Sinne.
Und da gibt es natürlich einen Unterschied zwischen jemandem,
der sich, wie heißt hier dieser, der ist so, wie schräg im Kopf,
der die Berliner Zeitung da gekauft hatte.
Ja, dieser Putin-Versteher. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ja, Berliner Zeitung habe ich eh nie gelesen. Und das ist aber auch das Schöne,
dem kann ich mich entziehen.
Holger Friedrich.
Ja, genau, irgendein komischer Typ.
Wenn da einer eine Zeitung kauft und dann steht da hier, pass auf,
der Spinne hat die Zeitung gekauft, muss eine andere Zeitung lesen.
Ist das halt was anderes, als wenn jemand ein soziales Netzwerk kauft und nach
seinem Sinne umgestimmt.
Und dann quasi den Menschen dort eine andere Realität wiedergegeben wird.
Die Zeit, die Menschen auf diesen sozialen Netzwerken verbringen und ja meinen
sich oder im Zweifelsfall sich auch tatsächlich in einem Austausch mit Menschen befinden.
Und das formt natürlich deine Wahrnehmung von dem, was akzeptabel ist,
von dem, was ein Problem ist und was keins ist.
Und deswegen ist das ja auch absolut diabolisch, solche sozialen Netzwerke zu betreiben.
Und erst recht dann quasi das verantwortungslos zu tun oder mit einer klaren
Agenda der Manipulationen.
Ja, ja. So.
Naja. Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Ja Tim, wir haben im Podcast, da müssen wir teilweise das eine oder andere noch mal sagen.
Ja genau, kommen wir zum Cyber. In der letzten Sendung habe ich ja gesagt,
okay, wie könnte man diese,
elektronische Patientenakte mit einem zeitgemäßen Zugriffsschutz versehen und
das wäre mit, wenn man die Krypto nutzt, auf der Karte.
Und dann hat sich, infolgedessen haben sich Leute mal DeTrust angeschaut.
Das ist im Prinzip so die digitale Identitäten-Dinger von der Bundesdruckerei,
die auch diese SMCB rausgeben.
Ja, das Security-Module-Card-Typ B, die Praxisausweise im weitesten Sinne.
Also du hast einen Connector, da kommt ein SMCB rein, damit weißt du dich dann
als Heilstätte aus oder Heilberuf,
Arzt oder was auch immer, wenn du jetzt da mitmachst und dann kannst du damit
an dieser Telematik-Infrastruktur teilnehmen und eben auch an der elektronischen Patientenakte.
Und ja, hat sich mal jemand angeguckt?
Können wir sowas auch bekommen? Das wäre doch mal schön.
Ja, das kannst du einfach bekommen. Martin hat das ja, haben wir alles erzählt,
kann man einfach bekommen.
Einzige Problem ist, du landest dann natürlich auch in so einer offenen API,
von Detrust und zwar hatten die einen API,
Endpunkt, wo sie sämtliche Bestellungen rausgegeben haben. Ohne Zugriffsschutz.
Also jeder, der da so ein Ding bestellt hat, dessen Daten, und das ist dann
Vorname, Nachname, E-Mail-Adresse, Geburtsdatum, teilweise Adresse und Ausweisdaten,
konnte man quasi dort mal eben rausholen.
Das war wieder ein Klassiker, ein API, wo am Ende der letzte Parameter eine
ID ist und wenn du die ID hochzählst,
dann kriegst du den nächsten und entsprechend gab es dann Cyberangriff,
weil jemand da ein paar runtergeladen hat.
Also große, große Thema. Jetzt hat Detrust dann irgendwie Strafanzeige erstattet
und steht dann in der Apothekerzeitung und auf Heise und hier Cyberangriff,
Cyberangriff und so weiter.
Dann habe ich jetzt mal mich heute übrigens dann doch gezwungen gesehen,
denen mal eine E-Mail zu schreiben.
Die E-Mail habe ich geschrieben an D-Trust, an den Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragte,
den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte und dann noch so ein paar Medien,
die darüber berichtet hatten,
dass da ein heimtückischer Cyberangriff auf D-Trust stattgefunden hätte.
Die will ich einfach mal ganz kurz vorlesen, weil ich ja ein bisschen in letzter
Zeit über unsere Aktivitäten bei der Vulnerability Disclosure gesprochen habe.
Sehr geehrte Bundesdruckerei D-Trust, ich wende mich an Sie als Sprecher des
Chaos Computer Club, der größten europäischen Vereinigung von Whitehead-Hackern.
Regelmäßig melden wir Sicherheitslücken und Datenlags den Verantwortlichen,
um potenzielle Betroffene zu schützen.
Unsere Hinweise erfolgen stets im Interesse der Allgemeinheit und ohne finanzielle Interessen.
Wie wir Medienberichten entnehmen konnten, haben Sie Strafanzeige erstattet,
nachdem über eine von Ihnen nicht geschützte API auf von Ihnen veröffentlichte
personenbezogene Daten zugegriffen wurde.
Unter API in Punkt XY haben Sie
ohne jegliche Schutzmaßnahmen datenfremder Bestellungen bereitgestellt.
Empfehlungen zur Behebung dieser Schwachstelle finden Sie hier.
Cheat Sheet Overs Insecure Direct Object Reference.
Also das ist die technische Bezeichnung dieser Schwachstelle,
wenn du etwas mit einer ID 1 hast und das nächste mit einer 2 und das nächste
mit einer 3 und derjenige,
für den 3 bestimmt ist, soll aber nicht auf die Wert 2 zugreifen.
Und was du da machen könntest, wäre natürlich einfach eine saubere Authentifizierung
vorher durchführen oder du könntest, wenn es schon sein muss,
quasi diese ID sehr lang und zufällig machen, sodass es schwierig wird,
eine zu erraten, die korrekt ist.
Das wäre so einfach erklärt, wie man eine Insecure Direct Object Reference verhindert.
Und ironischerweise ist das genau die gleiche Schwachstelle wie bei der elektronischen
Patientenakte, wo sie ja auch die Kartennummern hochzählen und die aber zum Geheimnis machen.
Also da lassen sie quasi die Passwörter hochzählen.
Gleiche Denkfehler. Okay, dann habe ich ihnen geschrieben, hiermit setzen wir
sie darüber in Kenntnis, dass die folgenden Zugriffe über XYVPN von einem anonymen
Sicherheitsvorscher und nicht von Kriminellen ausgingen. 3.
Januar, dann habe ich die Uhrzeiten und so weiter dahingeschrieben, bis 6. Januar, ne?
Der Sicherheitsforscher hat die von Ihnen verantwortete Sicherheitslücke unmittelbar
anonym an uns gemeldet und die restlose Löschung der Daten versichert.
Sofern keine weiteren Zugriffe neben den oben genannten erfolgt sind,
brauchen Sie daher keinen Missbrauch der von Ihnen ohne Zugriffsschutz veröffentlichten
Daten zu befürchten. Der Forscher handelte aus lauteren Motiven und ohne kriminelle Absicht.
Die rechtliche Grauzone des sogenannten Hacker-Paragrafen sowie ihre erstattete
Strafanzeige führten jedoch dazu, dass eine Meldung an sie nicht mehr zeitnah erfolgen konnte.
Bitte beachten Sie, dass wir als Chaos Computer Club lediglich diese Nachricht überbringen.
Wir möchten diese Gelegenheit jedoch nutzen, Sie persönlich darauf hinzuweisen,
dass Ihre Strafanzeige gegenstandslos ist, da die personenbezogenen Daten de
facto von Ihnen veröffentlicht wurden.
Entsprechend wurde auch kein Zugriffsschutz umgangen. Wir hoffen,
dass Ihnen ebenso wie uns ein Stein vom Herzen fällt, dass die von Ihnen ohne
Zugriffsschutz veröffentlichten Daten nicht in kriminelle Hände geraten sind.
Wir hoffen, dass sie ihre Energie nun darauf verwenden, ihr Sicherheitsniveau
an die gängigen Standards dieses Jahrhunderts anzuheben.
Beste Grüße, Linus Neumann, Chaos Computer Club.
Genau, Stand der Technik des aktuellen Jahrhunderts. Das wäre doch mal ganz
hilfreich. Ja, sehr schön.
Also tatsächlich, ja, also da hat diese Daten nochmal, das war vollständig ungeschützt.
Du musstest einfach nur dahin gehen, Parameter 1, Satz 1, Satz 2,
Satz 3 und dann kriegst du die gesamten Daten von allen, die da den Kram bestellt
haben. So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Wir hatten ja heute schon Kommentare von Max und Martino.
Bin mal gespannt, wie witzig die das finden, wenn die solche Karten nämlich.
Auch mal bestellen mussten und jetzt quasi dann da in einem derartigen potenziellen
Datenleck betroffen gewesen wären.
Und auch hier der Hinweis, die haben glaube ich am 13.
Sind die an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen und haben quasi gesagt,
hier hat jemand Daten abgegriffen.
Die haben das irgendwie gemerkt. Der Forscher hatte uns zu dem Zeitpunkt schon
Bescheid gesagt, dann haben die aber gesagt, ja, hier wird eine Strafanzeige erstattet.
Das heißt, wir haben dann erstmal irgendwie uns damit auseinandergesetzt und
dann weißt du auch immer nicht, wie reagierst du jetzt?
Hast du Lust, denen jetzt Bescheid zu sagen?
So mehr oder weniger zu sagen, naja, wir waren das, das ist ja das,
was ich hier sage, der Chaos Computer Club erklärt hiermit, die Daten wurden
gelöscht und es wurde aber auch nichts gehackt, ihr habt die einfach nur veröffentlicht.
Oder lässt du die mit dem Quatsch durchkommen, dass du da irgendwo überall schreiben,
es gab einen Cyberangriff.
Statt einfach mal zu schreiben, wir sind so unglaublich mit der Aufgabe überfordert,
die wir uns hier auferlegt haben, indem wir im Namen der Bundesdruckerei hier
irgendwie ein Trust Center betreiben.
Dass wir noch nicht mal irgendwie die OWASP-Schwachstellen irgendwie,
also so wirklich so einfachsten Kram,
weil wir wollen ja, wir sind ja hier der Vorreiter für sichere digitale Identitäten
und wir stärken das Vertrauen in die Digitalisierung.
Ja, also so ein Quatsch.
Ja, also ja, also D-Trust-Center heißt wahrscheinlich Distrust Center.
Distrust.
Also muss man so ein bisschen mit seinem Vertrauen ein bisschen zurückhalten.
Ah ja, unglaublich. Intensiv an der Auf, wir arbeiten intensiv an der Aufarbeitung
des Angriffs auf das Antragsportal für Signatur und Siegelkarten.
Dabei kooperiert die D-Trust eng mit den zuständigen Aufsichtsbehörden.
Auch die Strafermittlungsbehörden sind infolge der Strafanzeige der Detrust GmbH involviert.
Alter, ich würde mal ernsthaft, die Strafanzeige gehört eigentlich an die Typen
gesetzt, die hier irgendwie so eine Webseite betreiben im Namen der Bundesdruckerei
und alle irgendwie da rein scammen,
über irgendein unsicheres Webportal irgendwelche Kryptokarten zu bestellen.
Also, naja, ich bin mal gespannt, ob sich das noch weiterentwickelt.
Ich denke, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
vielleicht möchten die ja nochmal in unserem Podcast vorkommen.
Ist das so erstrebenswert eigentlich?
Nein.
Naja, also natürlich ist das ähm,
Auch etwas, wo man zweimal drüber nachdenkt, wenn er jetzt ein Strafermittlungsverfahren
ist und ich jetzt denen schreibe hier übrigens und ich habe denen ja auch gezeigt,
dass ich halt quasi Erkenntnisse habe, wann genau die Zugriffe waren und von
welchen VPN und so, das haben die ja nicht veröffentlicht.
Damit habe ich denen ja auch ein Beleg geliefert, dass ich Einsichten habe in
das, was eine anonyme Person da auf einem Weg, den ich nicht rückverfolgen kann, mir mal gemeldet hat.
Bin mal gespannt, ob die mich jetzt als Zeugen laden oder ob die einfach mal,
also ich sage gerne aus, wie absolut ungeschützt diese Systeme sind und wie
verantwortungslos, die ihre Plattform da betrieben haben. Kann ich gerne aussagen.
Vielleicht kriege ich ja eine Hausdurchsuchung, womit wir beim nächsten Thema wären.
Oha, ja, harte Nummer.
Jetzt kann man wieder mit Gerichtsnamen uns vertrotteln.
Immer aufpassen, wie die richtig heißen. Sonst gibt es gleich Kommentare.
Ich kann ja mal erzählen, was passiert ist und dann kannst du dir das,
wie das Gericht das bewertet hat, erzählen.
Dann suchst du schon mal die Gerichtennamen und so raus. Da machen wir ja immer Fehler.
Und pass auf, ob das Sachsen, Thüringen oder Leipzig ist oder irgendein anderes.
Hauptsache Italien.
Also ich erzähle mal, was passiert ist. Es gibt eine Hausdurchsuchung bei einem
Mann und dann sagt die Polizistin,
gib Handy und nimmt das Handy und sagt,
halt mal bitte deinen Finger hier auf diesen Fingerabdrucksensor,
damit das entsperrt wird.
Da sagt der Mann, ne.
Und dann sagt die Polizistin doch und beginnt zwangsweise seinen Finger auf diesen Sensor zu legen.
Also gib deinen Finger, gib Handy, gib Finger. Und dann hat er sich gewehrt.
Und dann haben sie ihn am Boden fixiert und das Telefon mit seinem Finger entsperrt.
So, dann ist die Situation.
So, jetzt würde man in einer normalen Welt, würde man jetzt vielleicht irgendwie
so sagen, okay, Polizistin suspendiert, Körperverletzung, rechtswidrige Maßnahme und so weiter.
Das wäre das, was man normalerweise erwarten würde. Aber wir sind in Deutschland,
das heißt, was passiert? der kriegt natürlich sofort eine Anzeige wegen Widerstand
gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte.
Weil die den zwingen mussten und weil der sich gewehrt hat.
Ja. Und dann hat er gesagt.
Hat er gleich eine Geldstrafe auch für bekommen vom Amtsgericht Bremerhaven.
Genau, und hat in Bremerhaven gesagt, ja, bist du verrückt, du kannst dich doch
nicht hier einfach gegen die Vollstreckungsbeamten wehren.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn jetzt hier jeder auf einmal die Maßnahme absolut
daneben ist und wahrscheinlich nicht rechtens sich auf einmal wehren kann.
Also ich meine, wo landen wir denn da?
Und interessanterweise wurde, also der Amtsgericht Bremerhaven eine Geldstrafe
bekommen, dann hat das Landgericht Bremen die bestätigt und dann hat der bestrafte Revision eingelegt.
Dann landet er eben vor dem Oberlandesgericht Und das Oberlandesgericht urteilt,
die Diensthandlung der einschreitenden Polizeibeamten mit Anwendung unmittelbarem Zwangs war rechtmäßig.
Und jetzt haben sie gesagt, dass die Polizei das gemacht hat.
Die Entsperrung eines Mobiltelefons durch Auflegen eines Fingers eines Beschuldigten
auf den Fingerabdrucksensor des Telefons kann auf die Ermächtigungsgrundlage
des Paragrafen 81b Absatz 1 StPO,
Strafprozessordnung, gestützt werden.
Also sie sagen in § 81b Absatz 1 der StPO steht drin, warum die das durften.
Und dieser Paragraf erlaubt unter
anderem die zwangsweise Aufnahme von Lichtbildern und Fingerabdrücken.
Ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, ich bin ja kein Jurist, aber ich würde mal vermuten,
da geht es darum, dass sie, wenn die Polizei dich irgendwie festhält,
dass sie ein Foto von dir machen dürfen und deine Fingerabdrücke nehmen dürfen,
also eine erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung.
So würde ich den Paragraphen jetzt mal, oder das würde ich vermuten,
hat sich mal jemand dabei gedacht, als dieser Paragraph formuliert wurde.
Ja genau, das ist sogar der Paragraph 81b. Erkennungsdienstliche Maßnahmen bei den Beschuldigten.
Das dürfen wir also machen. Ja, und jetzt sagt das Gericht, also die ganzen
Gerichte inklusive dem Oberlandesgericht,
der ist ja technikoffen formuliert, der Paragraf, und deswegen erlaubt er natürlich
auch ähnliche Maßnahmen,
zum Beispiel das Auflegen des Fingers auf diesen Sensor. Das ist ja eine ähnliche Maßnahme.
Und dann ist sie sogar noch geil. Und es ist sogar noch ein geringerer Eingriff,
weil sie hätten ja auch den Fingerabdruck abnehmen können, dauerhaft speichern können.
Und das wäre ja quasi der schwerwiegendere Eingriff gewesen.
Und den mal eben an das Handy halten, das ist ja wohl eindeutig von der SCPO gedeckt. Geil, oder?
Interessante Deutung der Dinge. Ich erinnere mich noch.
Das hast du davon, wenn ich mit Juristen einlässt.
Ehrlich gesagt. Ja und das war ja auch eine der Befürchtungen,
als so biometrische Verfahren eingeführt wurden, dass genau solche Zwangsmaßnahmen
dann gemacht werden, ähnliches mit Iris, Erkennung etc.
Also diese mafiösen Gebaren mit, jetzt schneiden wir mal den Finger ab und so weiter.
Das hat sich glaube ich jetzt nicht ganz so durchgesetzt, zumal ja glaube ich
auch die Systeme teilweise schon so Lebenderkennung auch noch mit drin haben.
Beim Fingerabdruck bin ich mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz so sicher.
Ob die Lebenderkennung haben? Ja, also.
Also das kann ich dir erklären. Also die haben jetzt nicht, die prüfen,
nicht nach einem Puls, aber die prüfen nach einem Hautwiderstand,
der, oder nach einem Leitungswiderstand, der ähnlich ist wie der einer Hautoberfläche.
Aber das hättest du auch noch beim abgeschnittenen Finger hättest du das wahrscheinlich auch noch.
Ja, das würde, also der, das, mir ist jetzt kein System bekannt,
ist auch, muss man auch sagen, Tim, ist natürlich schwer zu prüfen.
Du findest halt so wenig Freiwillige, wenn du es hast, wir wollen gucken, dass du wackelt.
Wir brauchen Unterstützung bei unseren Security-Tests. Hast du Lust, mal mitzumachen?
Du kriegst 10 Euro. Also das Entscheidende, diese Biometriegeräte sind weniger gegen,
also bei Fingerabdruck ist es weniger, dass du schützen musst gegen abgeschnittene
Finger, sondern versuchen musst zu schützen gegen Attrappen.
Und Attrappen baust du halt relativ einfach, nimmst du ein Foto von dem Fingerabdruck,
invertierst das, belichtest das auf eine Platine, dann also belichtest das auf
eine Platine, ätz dir quasi eine Platine mit dem Fingerabdruck.
Das machst du deswegen, weil du da schön diese Rillen kriegst durch diesen Ätzvorgang.
Dann machst du da ein bisschen Holzleim drüber, lässt den antrocknen,
damit du quasi wieder ein Positiv hast von dem Negativ.
Und dann hast du quasi etwas, was sich anfühlt für den Finger,
aber noch nicht leitet wie ein Finger.
Und dann machst du halt einen leichten Nebel von Grafittspray drauf und dann
hast du ungefähr die Leitfähigkeit von Haut.
Und ich glaube, zumindest alle iPhones, bis die aufgehört haben,
diese Sensoren da einzubauen, kriegst du damit geöffnet.
Als die Methoden, die Starbuck ermittelt hat, der hat auch, glaube ich,
ich weiß nicht vor wie vielen Jahren, auf dem Kongress präsentiert.
Und so machst du halt diese Fingerabdruckattrappen.
Bei Gesichtserkennung ist es ein bisschen anders. Da hast du auch nicht unbedingt
eine Lebenderkennung, aber ich weiß nicht, ob du dieses Feature an hast.
Beim iPhone zum Beispiel kannst du ja sagen, dass die Face-ID nicht funktioniert,
wenn du nicht hinguckst.
Also quasi, das ist so eine Art.
Naja, dem Lebenden noch eine Chance geben, sich zu weigern oder die Augen zu schließen oder so.
Aber klar, weißt du jetzt auch, wenn dir die Augen aufreißen,
musst du das auch über dich ergehen lassen und bist nachher noch dran wegen
Widerstand gegen Verschädigungsbeamte.
Und nur um das kurz zu Ende zu erzählen, bei dieser Iris-Erkennung,
Da gucken sie auch so ein bisschen nach lebend, also bei den Augen gucken sie
darauf, dass da so eine Reflexion drauf ist.
Da habe ich damals auch in Logbuch erzählt, das Video habe ich damals mit Starbucks zusammen gemacht,
wo quasi mit einer Infrarot-Kamera so ein Foto vom Auge gemacht und dann hat
dieses Ding das irgendwie immer nicht gefressen, Bis Starbuck irgendwann die Idee hatte,
eine Kontaktlinse da drüber zu legen, weil die Kontaktlinse feucht ist und diese
runde Oberfläche von einem Auge hat und entsprechend reflektiert und dann ging das Ding auch auf.
Kann ich da auch nochmal in den Shownotes verlinken. Aber okay,
genau, Lebenderkennung beim Finger, würde ich mal vermuten, hat kein Sensor.
Es war jetzt ja nicht genau gesagt, um was für eine Art Telefon es sich handelt.
Aber vielleicht auch nochmal so, als solltet ihr mal in so eine Situation kommen.
Ich kenne das jetzt nur, wie das beim iPhone so läuft, aber man kann natürlich
dann auch einfach erstmal die falschen Finger drauflegen. Das wäre sozusagen
der Quick-Fix, dass man also andere Finger nimmt.
Dass man vielleicht auch, wenn man da entsprechend paranoid ist,
generell andere Finger nimmt, als man jetzt üblicherweise vielleicht erwarten
würde. Sprich Zeigefinger, Daumen.
Kann man ja genauso gut auch mit dem Ringfinger machen. Und da man überall andere
Linien hat, nach drei Versuchen oder so, schaltet sozusagen diese Biometrieerkennung dann automatisch ab.
Wenn man das Telefon in der Hand hat, kann man halt auch einfach so...
Fünfmal irgendwie die Ein-Ausschaltetasse triggern.
Ich glaube, fünfmal ist Polizei rufen. Die sind ja in dem Fall schon da.
Ich glaube, du musst nur dreimal drücken.
Man tappelt da so ein bisschen drauf rum und dann ist im Prinzip die biometrische
automatische Erkennung auch sofort abgeschaltet.
Und nach einer bestimmten Zeit.
Sorry, ich habe es gerade hier. Dreimal hat nicht gereicht.
Ich glaube, fünfmal.
Fünfmal jetzt sagt er Aus- und Bullen rufen. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also es wurde immer davor gewarnt und ich habe ja auch hier in der Sendung schon
mehrmals gesagt, was ich mir wünschen würde, wäre,
dass das iPhone, wenn es mich biometrisch erkannt hat, einen einfacheren Code
verlangt und wenn es mich nicht biometrisch erkannt hat, einen längeren.
Dass ich quasi so eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung habe, nämlich einmal ein
einfacher Code, für den ich, was weiß ich, ja eh nur zehn Versuche habe und
mein Gesicht, also Wissen und Sein,
beide nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber wenigstens kein Single Point of Failure
und dass ich, wenn ich nicht erkannt wurde oder das Ding neu gebootet ist,
einen längeren Code eingeben muss, wie ich es jetzt mache.
Ich habe alphanumerische Code mit Tastatur und allem.
Genau, aber jetzt gibt es noch ein zweites Thema hier.
Also sie sagen ja gut, also die Maßnahme selber, dass sie den Fingerabdruck
von dem Jungen auf sein eigenes Telefon halten, das dürfen die.
Jetzt gibt es aber natürlich noch die Frage, die Polizistin hat ja in das Grundrecht
des Bürgers auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme
eingegriffen und da haben die Gerichte,
also in dem Fall in Ravensburg und in Baden-Baden gesagt, naja,
das war ja kein heimlicher Zugriff, das war ja ein offener Zugriff.
Und der ist ja in Ordnung und das ist ja hier allgemeine Grundsatz der Verhältnismäßigkeit
und da ist die Zwangsmaßnahme absolut in Ordnung, weil es wäre für die Polizei
ja sonst sehr viel schwieriger gewesen,
so ungefähr an diese Daten zu kommen.
Und eine Fingerattrappe anzufertigen, wäre ein viel tieferer Eingriff in die Rechte des Bürgers.
So, jetzt wird man noch sehen, ob sie die Daten auswerten dürfen.
Das war allerdings nicht Anlass für die Geldstrafe und daher jetzt auch nicht
Thema bei dieser Verhandlung vom OLG.
Aber ja finde ich schon echt irre also am Ende heißt das, dieser Mensch wurde,
unter Gewalt gezwungen, sein Telefon zu entsperren hat sich dagegen gewehrt
und wurde jetzt noch verurteilt wegen Widerstand.
Fällt mir immer wieder mein Lieblingsfilm Brasil ein, der auch viele so schöne
Zitate hat, was so moderne Dystopien betrifft Sondern da gibt es auch diese
wundervolle Formulierung mit, ja, das war bestimmt Simmons, der war schon immer
der Meinung, dass die Leute für ihre Verhöre mehr bezahlen müssen.
Ja, genau.
Ich hatte in der letzten Sendung ja auch über unseren Vortrag über Wahlsoftware
gesprochen und die Unternehmensstruktur dahinter,
dass sich da ein Unternehmen die gesamten anderen Anbieterinnen von Wahlsoftware aufgekauft hat.
Und da hat sich jetzt bei Netzpolitik.org nochmal, wie heißt da,
Sekunde, kurz den Namen des Autors.
Leonard Pitts.
Leonard Pitts hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt, hat ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert.
Und erstens, der Geschäftsführer der Vote Group sagt, über 90 Prozent der Kommunen
setzen Wahlsoftware aus deren Haus ein.
Und die Bundeswahlleiterin und sieben Landeswahlleitungen.
Also schon ziemlich signifikant.
Also man könnte sagen, wenn du sagst, über 90 Prozent der Kommunen setzen unsere
Software ein, dann glaube ich, werden sie mich für die Aussage,
dass eine marktbeherrschende Stellung nicht mehr belangen.
Also er hat alle Landeswahlleiterinnen angefragt Und teilweise haben die selbstentwickelte
Lösungen eingesetzt oder eben Produkte der Vote Group.
Es gibt keine einzige Landeswahlleitung, die einen anderen Hersteller benannt
hat. Also die sind marktbeherrschend.
Die gehören allerdings vollständig den kommunalen IT-Dienstleistern.
70% Regio-IT, das ist ein kommunaler IT-Dienstleister für Aachen und die Region.
Dann gibt es die Anstalt für kommunale Datenverarbeitung in Bayern,
die hält weitere 20% und der Rest verteilt sich so ein bisschen auf kleinere
kommunale IT-Dienstleister und den Wahlsoftware-Anwenderverein.
Und,
Da gibt es natürlich einen ganz lustigen Interessenkonflikt,
wenn nämlich die Kommune zu ihrem kommunalen Dienstleister kommt und sagt,
wir müssen hier eine Wahl machen und der sagt, da gibt es eine Software,
die gehört uns und es gibt sowieso keine andere mehr.
Und schließlich wiederholt sich dann natürlich wieder die Forderung,
wir brauchen endlich einen Vorrang für Open Source im Vergaberecht,
damit so etwas einfach Standard wird, dass man da nicht so einen Quatsch kriegt.
Auch sehr spannend ist, dass die relativ große Vorteile dadurch haben,
wenn der kommunale Dienstleister selber diese Software gehört weil sie dann
keine Ausschreibungen mehr machen müssen.
Also, Moment, wie ist es hier geschrieben?
Laut dem Wissenschaftlichen Institut für Infrastruktur und Kommunikationsdienste
können die IT-Dienstleister in der Regel Inhouse-Geschäfte mit den Kommunen,
die Träger, Mitglieder oder Gesellschaften der Unternehmen sind, abschließen.
Das bedeutet, dass die Kommunen Aufträge an sie direkt vergeben können.
Die Aufträge sind mehrwertsteuerfrei und versuchen und verursachen einen geringeren
organisatorischen Aufwand, weil keine Vergabeverfahren durchgeführt werden müssen.
Auch das ist natürlich, das nicht nur auf die Wahlsoftware begrenzt,
sondern betrifft alle möglichen Arten von Software. Also da schaffen sich auch
wieder, ich würde es mal sagen, ungesunde Strukturen.
Wenn du nämlich weißt, dass dein Unternehmen das eh machen muss und keine Konkurrenz hat.
Dann gibst du dir auch entsprechend viel Mühe.
Um das jetzt mal so freundlich zu sagen.
Ja, zumindest wenn es halt keine Open-Source-Verpflichtungen gibt,
was natürlich an der Stelle eigentlich sehr angemessen wäre.
Also eigentlich ist das ja ganz gut, dass wir hier so eine kommunale IT-Infrastruktur haben.
Finde ich ja völlig in Ordnung. Ich bin eh der Meinung, der Staat muss für seine
Infrastruktur halt auch selber sorgen.
Und dieses ganze Auslagern an Third-Party ist problematisch,
aber dann eben bitte auch Open-Source, einfach damit man,
ja, dass man das einfach überprüfen kann, dass man einfach sicherstellen kann,
dass da auch was ordentliches bei rauskommt und man sieht ja dann auch,
dass das dann eben schneller Folgen hat.
So ist es immer schwierig.
Also heißt es, dass jetzt diese Vote Group eigentlich überhaupt nicht so richtig
auf dem freien Markt ist, obwohl sie all die ganzen anderen Unternehmen gekauft
hat, befindet sich das sozusagen zwangsläufig jetzt alles unter kommunaler Kontrolle?
Äh, jein, weil, also ja, das gehört irgendwie den Kommunen.
Interessanterweise haben die
aber verhältnismäßig wenig Geld an Aachen beispielsweise ausgeschüttet.
Und dazu wird dann gesagt, wo man dann denkt, ach ja, wenigstens,
wenn die euch das ganze Geld da irgendwie abnehmen, dann würde man ja vermuten,
dass der Profit auch wieder an die Eigentümerinnen geht.
Und die Regio-IT schüttet ihren Gewinn zum Teil auch an ihre Gesellschaft aus.
So steht im Haushaltsplan der Stadt Aachen 2024, Seite 3666,
dass die Stadt für ihren direkten Anteil für das Geschäftsjahr 2022 eine Netto-Gewinnausschüttung
von 713.000 Euro erhielt.
Das sind sehr geringe Posten, weil die Stadt Aachen irgendwie einen Haushalt
von 1,2 bis 1,3 Milliarden hat.
Haben sich nicht dazu geäußert.
Das Unternehmen Regio-IT ist aber quasi, also diese 700.000,
die Aachen da bekommt, ist nur der Teil, den sie für Regio-IT bekommen.
Das heißt, für diese Wahlsoftware haben sie natürlich sehr, sehr viel weniger bekommen.
Und die Ausschüttung scheint nicht besonders hoch zu sein.
Und dann wird aber natürlich gesagt, ja, die Firma muss natürlich,
auch wenn sie der Stadt gehört, oder wenn sie anderen gehört,
sagt die Vote Group, macht ihr mit der Kohle?
Sagen die, wir müssen für die sichere Weiterentwicklung der Software,
für die wirtschaftliche Stabilität der Gesellschaft und für das Investment,
Zins und Tilgung ihrer Gesellschafter eine auskömmliche Reddite erwirtschaften.
Naja, bin mal gespannt, wer damit auskommt mit den paar hunderttausend Euro.
Okay, ja, also das war nochmal schön, wer sich dafür interessiert,
dass da einfach nochmal sehr viel weiter auf den Grund gegangen,
als wir da so ein bisschen bei North Data zurechtgeklickt haben.
Ich bin mir so erstaunt, was so Unternehmen alles so für, oder was Juristinnen
und Juristen Unternehmen immer für spannende Strukturen schaffen.
Wem dann das gehört und da und ach, auf einmal musst du keine Vergabeverfahren
mehr machen und keine Mehrwertsteuer und musst du nur der Stadt Aachen irgendwie
700.000 geben und musst du aber dann natürlich noch irgendwie ein bisschen wirtschaften
und erträgliches Auskommen. Das ist schon immer ganz gut für Theos zu machen.
Sollen wir jetzt endlich zu dem Thema kommen oder sollen wir Trump einfach skippen?
Fragst du mich das jetzt ernsthaft? Also, ja.
Also wir behandeln jetzt nicht den Ausstieg aus dem Pariser Klimaschutzankommen,
aus der Weltgesundheitsorganisation, die Aufgabe des staatsbürgerschaftlichen Geburtsrechts.
Die Begnadigung der Täter beim Sturm auf das Kapitol am 6.
Januar 2021, nicht das Ausrufen eines Energienotstands,
nicht das Ausrufen eines Notstands an der südlichen Grenze der USA und auch
nicht die Umklassifizierung tausender Staatsbeamter, damit man sie wahrscheinlich bald entlassen kann.
Und auch nicht, dass Hausgeräte weniger energieeffizient sein müssen,
sondern wir beschäftigen uns natürlich nur mit Trump-Themen,
die bei uns schon mal eine Rolle gespielt haben.
So wurde der Betreiber von Silk Road begnadigt, Ross Ulbricht oder besser bekannt
als Dread Pirate Roberts,
der eine Haftstrafe, eine lebenslange Haftstrafe plus 40 Jahre ohne Möglichkeit
einer Haftentlassung als Urteil bekommen hatte.
Und warum und ich glaube Tim, hilf meiner Erinnerung bitte auf die Sprünge,
ich glaube der hatte doch auch versucht Morde über,
Silk Road zu beauftragen Es gab den Vorwurf.
Er habe einen Auftragsmord ins Rollen gebracht das wurde ihm aber nie nachgewiesen und das wurde,
Mit anderen Worten, er ist eigentlich wirklich jetzt nur für diesen Betrieb
dieses Drogenverkaufsnetzwerks Silk Road verklagt worden. Das hat dann auch
schon irgendwie ausgereicht.
Zur Erinnerung, Silk Road war im Prinzip so die erste wirkliche Anwendung von Bitcoin.
Ja, also es war ja immer das, wir hatten das jetzt auch wieder in diesen Kommentaren,
es gibt ja immer noch diese Vorstellung, irgendwie Bitcoin wäre ja irgendwas
unglaublich revolutionäres technologisch.
Man hätte ja damit irgendwie Lösungen erzielt.
Man muss halt immer wieder betonen, als Zahlungsmittel taugen diese ganzen Cryptocurrencies
halt nur beim Erwerb von illegalen Dingen,
weil nur dann ist es überhaupt statthaft diese unsäglichen Transaktionskosten dafür zu bezahlen.
Weil man ja quasi überhaupt erstmal eine Möglichkeit hat, die man auf normal
kontrollierten Finanzwegen in der Regel so nicht hat.
Also man konnte bei Silk Road einfach per Bitcoin Drogen bestellen und dann
hatte man irgendwie da seinen Marihuana im Briefkasten.
Ich habe das selber nie ausprobiert, aber ich kenne Leute, die das ausprobiert
haben, das hat funktioniert.
Und ja, dann sind ihm ausreichend Fehler unterlaufen,
sodass ich glaube das FBI damals ihm auf die Spur gekommen ist und dann wurde
halt dingfest gemacht und am Ende eben auch verurteilt.
Also ein Mensch, der quasi so Dealership im größtmöglichen Maßstab betrieben
hat und da gibt es natürlich entsprechend Gesetze dagegen und auf Basis dieser
Gesetze ist er dann zu dieser doch eher längeren Haftstrafe,
also so zweifach lebenslang, plus 40 Jahre ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich lang.
Und vor allem auch ohne Möglichkeit einer Haftentlassung, dazu ist er dann halt
verdonnert worden. Und Trump so, ja, nö, irgendwie Bitcoin und so.
Das ist halt, also.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt, also gut, der hat ja die Webseite betrieben.
Also schuldig gesprochen für Gründung und Betrieb einer kriminellen Organisation,
Verschwörungen zum Handeln mit Drogen, Geldwäsche und Verschwörungen zu Computerhacking.
Und du hast recht, wegen Mordaufträgen, da wurde er nicht für verurteilt.
Man kann schon sagen, dass das ein extrem hartes Urteil ist für jemanden,
der eine Webseite betrieben hat.
Das auf jeden Fall, gar keine Frage. Also ich wollte das jetzt auch nicht rechtfertigen, das Strafmaß.
Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, das war das sozusagen, was halt verhängt wurde.
Okay, den hat Trump jetzt begnadigt.
Vor seiner Amtseinführung hat er einen Krypto-Coin gemacht. Ey,
ich meine, also, what the fuck?
Was war das am Wochenende vor seiner Amtseinführung? Launcht er irgendeinen
beknackten Krypto-Coin?
Also, ich meine,
es soll...
Und dann gab es den Melania-Coin.
Ja, es ist einfach Grifter unter sich.
Also ich meine, das kriegt man halt jetzt, wenn man sich irgendwie diese Posse eingetreten hat.
Also diese ganzen Glücksritter, die halt jetzt über jetzt ein Jahrzehnt den
anderen Leuten die Kohle abgenommen haben und mit diesen Pump-und-Dump-Schemes
und anderen Methoden halt künstlich immer diese Preise dieser Coins hochgehalten haben.
Mit einem Rechtssystem, was oder einem Finanzrechtssystem, was mit diesen Trends
offensichtlich ausreichend überfordert war und dann teilweise das eben auch
legalisiert hat oder zumindest nicht gleich verboten hat, wie es richtig gewesen wäre.
Immer so mit dieser Unterstellung, es würde sich jetzt dabei um irgendwas ganz
Tolles und Nützliches halten, was man halt einfach mal ausschließen kann,
weil nennen wir mal einen Ding,
wo die Welt, die Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form davon profitiert hat.
Also fällt mir halt gar nichts zu ein. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Die Killer-Apps waren halt Silk Road, also Drogenhandel und die andere Killer-App
ist halt Terrorfinanzierung.
Und die dritte Killer-App, die wir jetzt auch noch täglich haben,
ist halt Betrugs- Erpressungsfälle.
Hier, wir haben ja deine Webseite verschlüsselt und deine Backups zerstört.
Wenn du deine Daten wieder haben willst, zahlst du hier in Bitcoin.
Das sind also die Geschäftsmodelle, die eigentlich durch Cryptocurrency ermöglicht
wurden und das einzige halbwegs legale System, was sich daraus entwickelt hat,
ist, dass es halt einfach so ein Trading ist, so ein Asset-Trading.
Also eben so wie Aktienhandel, aber halt völlig überdreht. Im Prinzip wie so ein Kunstmarkt.
Und da ist es dann eben auch kein Wunder, dass dann eben solche Meme-Coins und
irgendwie NFTs und wir machen jetzt hier irgendwie jeder macht jetzt nochmal so seine eigene,
Währung auf, was ja meistens immer nur so Cover-Up- Krypto-Dinger sind,
die auf irgendeine bestehende Infrastruktur, in der Regel halt Ethereum,
aufsetzt und dann irgendwie einfach nur nochmal separat vermarktet wird und
dann gibt es genug Doofe, die der Meinung sind, oh, wenn ich das jetzt kaufe,
dann ist da Wertsteigerung und wir werden alle reich.
Aber so funktioniert das halt irgendwie nicht, weil irgendwann haben wir alle
genug Tulpen und dann verfallen halt diese Preise gleich wieder.
Und Trumps Wahlkampf ist halt einfach massiv von Leuten finanziert worden.
Aber der hat, also ich meine, ich finde es schon nochmal,
also ja, hast du jetzt alles nochmal gut erklärt, aber dass der Präsident eines,
also der ehemalige und neu werdende Präsident eines Landes so ein,
also ein absolut erkennbares Abzockding nochmal eben rausfährt.
Und damit irgendwie laut berichten, das ist natürlich jetzt,
also die Zahl fliegt da rum, ich habe das jetzt nicht analysiert oder bestätigt,
dass er ein paar hundert Millionen gemacht hätte.
Weiß ich nicht, weil man nicht weiß, zu welchen Preisen er gehandelt hat,
wie auch immer, ich habe mir das gar nicht angeschaut, aber stell dir mal vor,
wenn der nächste Kanzler,
oder der übernächste, sagen wir irgendein Kanzler in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
irgendwie noch, weiß ich nicht, so zwei Tage vor der Amtseinführung sagt,
ey Leute, ich habe noch einen geilen Krypto-Coin für euch.
Also ich meine, da wäre so der Moment, wo ich mir anfangen würde, Sorgen zu machen?
Also Sorgen habe ich mir bei Trump schon vor langer, langer Zeit gemacht und
mittlerweile bin ich über diesen Zustand schon längst hinaus.
Also ich nehme das zwar mit einiger Erschütterung zur Kenntnis,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich nicht damit gerechnet habe.
Das wird jetzt halt auch so weitergehen. Hab ich ja letztes Mal schon so ausgeführt.
Ja, trotzdem muss man ein bisschen überrascht tun. Da hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet.
Ich muss echt sagen, Das ist so bescheuert und das hat auch noch funktioniert.
Das finde ich noch bescheuerter. Naja, okay, gut, hat er gemacht,
damit ist er es abschließend erörtert, das Geld ist weg, es ist bei Trump.
Und dann hat er gesagt, dieses TikTok-Verbot, das soll sofort wieder sein.
Und mein neuestes Trump-Zitat ist, ich glaube, das ist sinngemäß,
I think the United States is entitled to owning half of TikTok.
Und das wäre einfach so geil, dass du irgendwie sagst so, okay,
ich glaube, es steht uns zu, dass uns die Hälfte davon gehört.
Das ist irgendwie jetzt mein neuer Spruch, wenn irgendjemand was Nettes hat,
denke ich, mir steht die Hälfte davon zu.
Und dann muss man sich natürlich fragen, wer hat denn eigentlich die Idee gehabt,
dieses TikTok-Verbot da ins Rollen zu bringen?
Und dass Donald Trump da jetzt schön rückhängig gemacht hat. Ja, war Donald Trump.
Der war der Erste, der öffentlich ein TikTok-Verbot ins Gespräch brachte und zwar 2020.
Und da hat er gesagt, entweder soll TikTok sich von seinem chinesischen Mutterkonzern
ByteDance trennen oder es wird in den USA verboten.
Und zwar hat er gesagt, erstens geht es hier um Datenschutz,
ausgerichtet auf einmal sorgen die Amerikaner sich um Datenschutz und dass die
App also die Daten amerikanischer Bürger an die chinesische Regierung weitergeben könnte.
Und natürlich eine Frage der nationalen Sicherheit, weil das zur Spionage oder
Beeinflussung von Meinungen genutzt werden könnte.
Genauso, wie es jetzt irgendwie mit X in den USA passiert ist und zu nennenswerten
Teilen auch in Deutschland gerade passiert.
Da hat der Trump gesagt, nee, das wollen wir nicht, das halten wir nicht so gerne.
Da hat er nämlich ein Executive Order gemacht und das Verbot von TikTok angeordnet.
Das wurde aber gerichtlich blockiert.
Aber sein Ziel war eben, dass er die Operationen von TikTok,
die US-Operationen an ein US-Unternehmen verkaufen will.
Das ist nach wie vor sein Ziel und deswegen hat er dieses TikTok-Verbot,
was jetzt vom Gericht ja bestätigt wurde,
erstmal außer Kraft gesetzt für ich glaube 75 Tage, um quasi denen Zeit zu geben,
einen Deal zu finden und das an irgendeinen Amerikaner zu verkaufen.
Und da wird jetzt tatsächlich der Name Elon Musk irgendwie rumgedacht.
Also das ist, finde ich auch, also was, Irrsinn.
Ja, man muss an der Stelle mal auch sich klar machen,
welche Bedeutung TikTok mittlerweile hat Also ich denke so hier in unserer Community
ist wahrscheinlich die Zahl der TikTok-Abonnenten und Konsumenten sehr überschaubar
Und man blickt da drauf halt immer so ein bisschen als irgendwie,
ja das ist ja hier dieses Toy für Kids irgendwie mit den lustigen Videos Und
wer schaut sich das schon so an?
Aber auch in Deutschland, aber vor allem eben in den USA, hat TikTok mittlerweile
eine riesige Nutzerschar.
Ich glaube die letzte Zahl, die ich gehört habe in den USA alleine 150 Millionen.
Das ist so quasi schon die gesamte USA.
Wenn du mal davon ausgehst, 300 Millionen, dann hast du irgendwie ein paar Kinder
und ein paar sehr alte und so weiter.
Also es erreicht quasi alle. und na klar ist halt TikTok von den Chinesen mitgesteuert,
da können die noch so viel behaupten, das ist vollkommen klar und natürlich
werden darüber genauso wie über X und wie über alle anderen sozialen Netzwerke Kampagnen gefahren.
Und das ist natürlich eine Gefahr, weil Trump möchte natürlich gerne selber
der Herrscher über alle Right-Wing-Kanäle sein und dann sollen nicht irgendwie
die Chinesen auf einmal irgendwie was machen, sondern das wollen sie selber haben.
Deswegen wollte er es auch nicht verbieten, sondern er droht einfach nur mit
dem Verbot, um in irgendeiner Form zu erzwingen, dass man sich dort einkaufen kann.
Zumindest zu 50 Prozent, dass
man bestimmte Dinge eben ausreichend verhindern oder mit anstoßen kann.
Das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen so ein Sharing mit so, ja macht doch ihr irgendwie
in Asien hier mit eurem TikTok, was ihr wollt, aber hier in den USA,
da wollen wir ja die Propaganda mitgestalten und das ist so ein bisschen der Hintergrund.
Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, wie erfolgreich das sein kann und sein
wird, aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Grund.
Also hier geht es einfach ganz klar um die Kontrolle der Gesellschaftsmedien,
um die Gesellschaft weiterhin zu kontrollieren.
Ja Und das ist ja jetzt auch hier bei diesem zweiten Projekt,
was da verkündet wurde diese Stargate-Geschichte das geht ja im Prinzip genau
in die gleiche selbe Richtung.
Ja, da möchten sie jetzt sicherstellen, dass sie in dieser neuen Technologie
der künstlichen Intelligenz mit unbegrenzt Geld und kaum Regulierung die KI-Macht des Planeten werden.
Und da hat Trump jetzt gesagt, okay, 500 Milliarden.
Also in Deutsch deutsche Milliarden, eine halbe Billion soll in den nächsten vier Jahren in OpenAI,
Oracle und Softbank fließen oder von denen kommen, in jedem Fall irgendwie in
künstliche Intelligenz investiert werden.
Und da kannst du eigentlich nur mit den Ohren schlackern, weil das natürlich
wirklich eine Summe ist, die sowas von irre groß ist und wenn du die,
in OpenAI pumpst und in dann noch Oracle als quasi Datenbankunternehmen,
Datensammlungsunternehmen, dann wirst du damit auch die KI-Macht des Planeten.
Wir sind es ja eh schon, aber also das ist ein Schritt, der wahrscheinlich nicht
besonders doof ist von Donald Trump.
Und wo man sich als europäischer Bürger durchaus fragen muss,
ob denn irgendwo nochmal jemand in Europa wirklich Interesse hat,
in diesem Technologie Bereich noch zu kompieten?
Oder war das jetzt wie quasi alles vorher auch schon?
Den USA überlassen und den Regeln, die sie schreiben. Wir haben die Runde ja schon einmal durch.
Internet ist da, zack, Google.
Soziale Medien kommen, zack, Facebook, zack, Twitter.
Also immer diese, keine Ahnung, Betriebssystem kommen, zack, Microsoft.
Und immer diese wirklich irre Markt- und Gesellschaftsdominanz,
die jetzt bei Produkten wie jetzt Microsoft Office schon nervt,
aber gut ist dann eben Industriestandard, macht das Unternehmen Milliarden mit, wunderbar,
andere zahlen dafür, wäre natürlich schön gewesen sowas in Deutschland zu haben,
Aber wenn es jetzt um quasi sehr viel weitergehende Technologien geht, wie eben, ja,
sogenannte soziale Netzwerke, die dann am Ende einen unglaublichen Einfluss
auf unser Erleben und unsere Gesellschaft haben und dann Technologien, die Computer,
Interfaces und Datenverarbeitung wirklich revolutionieren und die sehr klar,
Ich meine, es ist ja immer noch ganz nett, dass es ab und zu noch so ein paar
KI-Lächler gibt, die sagen, ach ja Quatsch, das kann nicht alles viel besser oder so.
Aber ich meine, dass diese Technologie dann doch ungefähr alles,
was IT ist, auf den Kopf stellen wird oder vielleicht auch erstmal auf die Beine
stellen wird, ist glaube ich schon relativ klar.
Uns ist das klar. Aber ich glaube, das haben noch nicht alle verstanden.
Also Europa, das können wir vergessen. Also ich meine, wir haben einfach in
Europa in den letzten 20 Jahren zu keinem Zeitpunkt irgendwie nennenswert dafür gesorgt,
dass es auch nur ansatzweise eine konkurrenzfähige Wirtschaftsstruktur geben
kann, die in der Lage ist,
diesen selben Druck im Innovationsbereich zu entfalten.
Also das ist halt einfach mit unserer Mentalität erstmal dem ganzen europäischen
Infighting und diesem Abgrenzen,
wo jetzt in welchem Land, wo was gebaut werden darf und ja, nee,
also bevor wir uns dann in Europa auf irgendwas einigen, müssen erstmal alle
nationalen Befründe erstmal abgesichert werden.
Das verhindert schon mal sehr viel.
Und wenn wir dann einfach mal wieder nach Deutschland schauen,
also jeder, der hier irgendwie mal versucht hat, ein Unternehmen zu gründen
und sich dann mit Banken und Investoren hat rumschlagen müssen und die ganzen Auflagen.
Da wundert das einfach nicht, dass die dann eben alle nach Silicon Valley ausmarschieren,
weil dann einfach dort sich eben zwangsläufig das ganze Geld und dann zwangsläufig
daraufhin auch noch eben das Personal sammelt.
Deswegen werden dort so absurde,
Gelder bezahlt. Ich meine, es ist nicht alles Gold, was da ist und wir sehen ja jetzt auch,
wie sich dieser ganze Tech-Sektor auch durchpolitisiert durch diese libertären
Tendenzen und diese ganzen Träumer-Typen wie Musk und Thiel etc.,
die halt in ihrem Long-Termism irgendwie nur noch von irgendwie Mars-Besiedlung
träumen und einfach so völlig absurde Zukunftsfantasien haben und dabei einfach
die Gegenwart komplett ignorieren.
Und dann auch einfach überhaupt gar kein soziales Gewissen mehr haben.
Da geht es halt einfach nur noch um Macht und Einfluss.
Und jetzt sehen wir einfach durch
die KI-Technik, also ich kann das nur unterstreichen, was du gesagt hast.
Und wem das noch nicht klar ist, bitte check das jetzt mal.
Das ist einfach die dominierende Technologieentwicklung der nächsten Jahre.
Das wird alles mitreißen. Und meinst du nicht Dieselmotor?
Also ich könnte mir schon vorstellen.
Dass es Dieselmotor ist. da müsste man nochmal gucken, was geht sicherlich,
also da wird sich Deutschland noch ein paar Jahre mit,
beschäftigen, ob da nicht noch vielleicht noch was zu holen ist,
aber der Rest der Welt zieht halt von dann und ja, den Energiesektor muss man
auch noch mit reinnehmen und das ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Bild,
also gucken wir mal wo ist das Militär stark,
wo äh ist so Entrepreneurship irgendwie problemlos möglich?
Wo ist die Computertechnologie,
im Bereich Hardware-Chip-Entwicklung ganz vorne und wo ist die Software-Entwicklung,
sprich AI-Technologie, Betriebssysteme, Programmiersprachen etc.
Ganz vorne. Und dann siehst du einfach, dass wir...
Ich weiß es, Tim. In Silicon Saxony In Silicon Saxony ist das.
Thüringen wolltest du sagen.
Wir haben eine bipolare Welt und die besteht aus den USA und aus China.
So, das ist halt einfach das Ding, dass wenn die Russen auch nicht gerne hören,
die halt immer noch der Meinung sind, sie könnten da mit ihren imperialen Kriegen
was machen, sich dabei aber einfach selber ruinieren.
Deswegen interessiert ja auch Trump jetzt Putin nicht mehr und will jetzt glücklicherweise
dann dafür sorgen, dass der Ukraine-Krieg beendet wird. Good luck with that.
Ich hoffe, das findet jetzt auch bald statt. Aber die eigentliche Auseinandersetzung
ist halt zwischen China und den USA.
Und das sehen wir an dieser TikTok-Geschichte, das sehen wir bei diesen AI-Investments
und das sehen wir eben auch beim derzeit noch politischen Kampf um Taiwan.
Weil Taiwan ist halt der.
Quasi der Schlüsselkampf in dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher, ob die USA in der Lage sind,
Taiwan zu halten, aber das sollte auf jeden Fall das Ziel sein,
weil das ist halt einfach mal das Zentrum der Chip-Entwicklung auf diesem Planeten.
Und wenn die Chinesen es schaffen, sich auch Taiwan einzuverleiben,
dann verändern sich halt die Kräfte nochmal weiter.
Also das ist der Battle, der hier abläuft und man kann halt Trump alles mögliche
vorwerfen, seine Ideologie, seine Ignoranz, seine mangelnde Empathie und alles.
Und natürlich sind diese ganzen Republikaner alle kleine Schnuller-Nazis,
die einfach alle an einer Waffel haben und Unsinn reden und so weiter, nur.
Die sehen schon irgendwie auch den eigentlichen Power-Struggle der Zukunft und
konzentrieren sich irgendwie da drauf.
Leider eben ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste dabei, aber da spielt er sich ab und
das ist halt eigentlich die ganze Botschaft dieser Initiationswoche,
die wir da jetzt erleben.
Ja, also schön, dass wir da nochmal so eine fröhliche Note dann von dir zum Ende.
Ja, kein Problem. Goldene 20er, das muss ja auch unterfüttert werden.
Kommen wir zu einem Termin.
Ich hoffe, dass man es nicht in dieser Aufnahme gehört hat, dass wir dann doch
ein bisschen Verbindungsschwierigkeiten hatten. Der Tim hat das bestimmt alles
noch schön wieder so hingeschrieben, dass man unsere kleinen Sprechunterbrechungen
und Pausen nicht so hört.
Deswegen gebe ich freiwillig meinen Anspruch auf die Musik auf an dieser Stelle
und kündige den Winterkongress an der Digitalgesellschaft Schweiz.
Und zwar am Freitagabend, 28.
Februar geht es los und am Samstag, 1. März geht es weiter in Winterthur.
Wieder ungefähr 30 Vorträge zu netzpolitischen Themen und der digitalen Gesellschaft
und es gibt ein Nerdquiz und der Ticketverkauf ist bereits gestartet.
Alle Infos findet ihr unter winterkongress.ch.
Winterkongress in Winterthur. 28. Februar und 1. März.
Und Kongress mit K. Ganz ungewöhnlich.
Ja.
Alright. Ja. Super.
Ja, wir sind beide gerade viel unterwegs und haben Zeitzonen und Verbindungs-
und WLAN-Issues und so weiter.
Aber I do my very best, dass wir das hinbekommen.
Wir kriegen das hin und das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass wir das hinkriegen.
Ja.
Wollen wir noch irgendwas Positives mit auf den Weg geben oder lassen wir einfach
die Depression und die Dystopie so im Raum stehen?
Wir haben ja ein paar positive Sachen. Ich meine, was denn?
Was war denn nochmal?
Ich scroll nochmal durch.
Sicher?
Na, warte. Doch, hier, Moment. Nee, nee, haben wir nicht.
Haben wir nicht. Sorry, haben wir nicht. Okay, das war's von uns.
Okay, Leute, macht euch weiserhin auf unregelmäßige Erscheinungen gefasst,
aber wir hören uns bald wieder. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.